We were asking really
basic questions
and very limited questions.
How does estrogen control
thermal regulation?
What is the function of
these neurons in reproduction
and in thermal regulation?
And we didn't know in advance
that they would have anything
to do with thermal regulation.
The research has led to a
non-estrogen replacement
therapy treatment
of hot flashes.
And to this point,
the other treatments
have not been effective or
have had too many side effects.
It's just beyond
belief that I would
be the world's expert
on estrogen modulation
of thermal regulation.
I mean, how could that happen?
I should be competing
with hundreds of people
really to study this.
To me, that seems absurd.
There should be
an entire research
field studying regulation
of temperature by estrogen.